hey everyone this is national master
Costa Kavinsky here for chess calm and
today I'm going to be talking about a
very common checkmate tactic known as
the back rank checkmate the back rank
mate is usually happening when one sides
last rank is exposed and vulnerable and
thus the king can be checkmated from the
side in this position here Y can
immediately win the game by playing rook
c8 check since black King cannot jump
over his own pawns then blacks only
legal move here is to play Queen d8 and
then after white takes the Queen he has
checkmate so the back rank mate is
something that experienced players are
constantly looking for in their games to
see if they can take advantage of the
king usually ends up here because black
is Castle kingside and white also Castle
kingside
and when some of the major pieces get
traded off like Queens and rooks then
oftentimes this back rank is left open
and if one side can take advantage of it
it is usually enough to win the game so
let's look at another example in this
position we see that the black King
Castle kingside but he still has two
rooks protecting his back rank and he
even made an escape square for his King
by pushing this pawn forward however as
we'll see here it's not enough to avoid
potential back rank issues because White
has his pieces lined up on the e-file
and is ready to start attacking black on
the back rank in this position why it
has a winning move here which I
recommend you trying to find by pausing
your video and taking a minute or two
and go ahead and try to see if you can
find the winning move here for white
taking advantage of blacks back
okay so the winning move here is to play
rook takes b7 after this move white wins
a full piece black's rook cannot
recapture because if he does he's going
to get checkmated on i-89 escape because
White's Bishop is protecting the square
so here we can see an example of where
even though black took some precautions
such as leaving major pieces on his back
rank and even creating an escape for his
King he still got into some trouble so
this is a very dangerous
tactic that you need to look out for in
your games a good way to have prevented
this trick in this particular position
would probably event to defend this
bishop with another piece such as the
Queen but the main point is that even
when everything seems protected you
should still look out for back rank
tactics so let's move on to our last
example in this position white again has
lined up some major pieces on the e-file
and is looking to attack blacks back
rank of course everything here also
seems protected as this rook is
protected by the Queen and the other
rook whoever here white realized that if
he can deflect black's Queen away from
defending his rook Y would be able to
win the game due to the back rank tricks
so in this position white played queen
g4 seemingly offering up his queen for
free but of course if black takes his
Queen he's going to be checkmated
immediately on eight
black was forced to run away with this
Queen since his Queen was also attacked
and he played Queen b5 and now comes the
next part Queen c4 now what hangs is
Queen to two-piece
is the black Queen and the black rook
but both of these pieces are busy
defending the e8 rook
so black takes the Queen with either
piece he again is going to get
checkmated on the back rank so black was
forced to go back to d7 now comes Queen
c7 again the Queen is untouchable so
black continues to run away with this
Queen while white continues to harass
this Queen and tries to get him away
from defending this rook on e8 so why
played a four just leaving his Queen on
c7 black has to take the pawn and now
rookie four so why leaves his Queen
undefended on c7 and even offers up his
rook but like the Queen the rook is also
untouchable if black takes then why it
will take on c8 and again black ends up
being in serious trouble so black is
forced to go back to b5 and now comes
the last move Queen takes b7 and as you
can see the Queen here the black Queen
has run out of squares that you can go
to that are safe and that you can keep
protecting this rook so black lost the
game so background check mates are very
common because usually both sides Castle
kingside
and rarely do beginner players remember
to create some sort of escape square for
the King also sometimes these escape
squares aren't very useful because white
or black can have a piece that attacks
that escape square and thus making it
kind of useless so in order to avoid
back rank mates there's a couple of
different things you can do along with
creating some sort of escape score for
your King you should always make sure to
challenge any open file
that there is usually these back rank
tactics occur because one side has
control over the only open file and thus
this control and power leads to tactics
because they're controlling that last
square on the back rank so if you can
challenge the open file safely then
usually this should be enough to avoid
back rank tricks but of course if you
can control the open file yourself then
you should always make sure to look out
for any tricks that you have exposing
your opponent's back rank so thanks a
lot for listening and I will see you
soon on chess comm